IF THE THUNDER CAN FIND A WAY TO
GET A TWO OR A THREE HERE WITH
6.9 SECONDS LEFT.
>> Michael: YOU PRACTICE THIS
PLAY.
ALL YOU NEED IS A TWO TO TIE THE
BALL GAME.
>> Chris: MUSCALA, BACK TO THE
BASKET LOOKING TO DISTRIBUTE.
FINDS SHAI.
SHAI STEPS BACK ON THE THREE.
AT THE BUZZER, IT IS GOOD!
AND SHAI GILGEOUS-ALEXANDER
SHREDS THE HOPES OF THE CLIPPERS
HERE A PAYCOM CENTER WITH A BIG
THREE.
>> Michael: YOU TALK ABOUT A
DREAM SHOT.
AND THAT, MY FRIEND, IS WHY YOU
ALWAYS STICK AROUND FOR AN NBA
BALL GAME.
YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN NEXT BECAUSE A COUPLE OF
NIGHTS AGO, THE THUNDER HAD THIS
HAPPEN TO THEM AS WELL.
>> Chris: IT IS A THREE AT THE
BUZZER.
THE REVIEW SAYS THE SHOT COUNTS,
AND IT'S AT THE BUZZER.
NO TIME LEFT.
AND A WIN FOR OKC.
SGA WITH A KISS GOOD NIGHT TO
THE CLIPPERS.
>> Michael: YOU'VE GOT TO
UNDERSTAND HIS MINDSET RIGHT
NOW.
BECAUSE AGAINST THE PELICANS A
COUPLE OF NIGHTS AGO, YOU SAW
THE LOOK OF JUST SHOCK AND
DISBELIEF.
AND THEN TONIGHT, HE MAKES THAT